what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation look who's in town Sally
lamanako is here with us today I still
get my name wrong Sally's visiting I was
like well
why hang out we should shoot a movie
reaction together I gotta participate in
her uh Spider-Man Mary Jane short film
we shot something for it keep a lookout
for that it'll be out in six to eight
years I'm really excited for it I
believe in you thank you six to eight
years is a good amount of time to get
your 10 minute short film done it's
gonna be like 30 minutes guys that's a
long short film I know you should make
it 10 minutes well then I'll have to cut
you out though you should make it 30
minutes hey leave a like cause Sally's
in town right yeah yeah just please
leave a like if I get to 500 likes I'll
move back to L.A so ambitious no why are
you crossing your arms are you
uncomfortable no I'm itching my arm all
right okay my arms making sure I can't
read your body language
copy of Roger Pitch Perfect that's why
we said yeah I didn't even mention that
we've never seen it just so happened to
be wearing a shirt that is a great song
there you go so patreon we have for our
super sexy rejects where you stick up
with your own copy of Pitch Perfect we
could watch the whole thing with us we
also got exclusive content as well oh
yeah uh Sally's uh she's not doing the
Marvel reactions here anymore
let's roll that intro I'm getting chewed
out for and my DMs are like well you
couldn't even commit to doing this yeah
what's your problem I'm like listen I
was shooting them all really fast and I
was on it correct the one that's like
let's hold this there's a hole Yeah you
deserve it I have to lead this Channel
and it's important that the leader never
takes blame right and only points to
everyone else right that is what you
learned from 21 irrefutable laws of
leadership let's roll that intro
from me
is that an acapella yeah I have no clue
what this movie's about it's just about
singing I have zero idea I assume it's
called pitch perfect please don't stop
them please don't stop though please
don't stop the music
I love acapella now this is exactly the
type of performance you would expect to
see at the International Championship I
didn't know she was in this nothing
makes a woman feel more like a girl than
a man who sings like a boy
look at you you're a mess you're
unfocused you dumb [__]
my dad always says if you're not here to
win get the hell out of Kuwait has your
dad ever told you to shut up yeah I'm on
her side team Selena please don't stop
the music boy that hurts sexy man split
his pain is our game Gail
[Laughter]
is this movie about acapella yes it's
acapella groups oh no way yeah
[Music]
it's a horrible song
oh this is cool
I love this
I'm turning a snoozeville yeah and we
park in a lot where they do not validate
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was nasty we know exactly where it
is
[Music]
yeah this movie has Style
I love Anna Kendrick
[Laughter]
this guy looks so familiar
there he is oh there's been plaid I love
Ben wow looking at it now I can see that
it's a bit much
I could take it down no it's Michael
Tessler
just uh it's your old man making a funny
Chris Rock everybody
that
DJing is not a profession it's a hobby I
want to produce music I want to make
music you're going to get a college
education first for free I would not
have this conversation like in front of
someone yeah so drop that you're getting
a free college education
[Applause]
Dane Cook yes I was gonna say he looks
like a young version of Dane Cook
troublemakers
of acapella
how's your voice
[Music]
oh nice
it's an awkward thing I am confident
that we will find eight super hot girls
with bikini ready bodies who can
harmonize in a perfect pitch okay oh
this is gonna be a great movie this is
try me
[Music]
call yourself Fat Amy yes so twig
[__] let you know behind my back
diff juice
that's not a real word but keep trying
you will get there
laughs
there's four groups on campus the Bellas
that's us the bu harmonics they sing a
lot of Madonna the high notes they're
not particularly motivated I get it are
we sing all over the world and we
compete in National Championships on
purpose
we played the Cobb Energy Performing
Arts Center you [__] oh wow
and bumper huge fan the smell of your
weird is actually affecting my vocal
cord so I'm gonna need you to
what a dick
it's like acapella gangs yeah it's like
West Side Story
yeah
Annie has an accent my God yes I know
I'm Luke station manager you must be
Becky the intern
um it's uh hey man what's up I'm Jesse
I'm Luke you're late I know you no you
don't no you don't
now you guys will be spending a lot of
down time together so please just no sex
on the desk I've been burned before what
a shitty rule one of those girls is all
dark and mysterious and she takes off
her glasses and that amazingly scary ear
Spike and you realize that you know she
was beautiful the whole time no more
glasses then you're halfway there
oh oh dick
out of here
jokes aren't even funny it was a
compliment
he was saying you're hot no you were
saying you were half hot
get a little let me mansplain this to
you
I just always get mad at me
I got a job at the radio station oh
great that place yeah it's dark and
dirty and has like what those three
weirdos who work there well four now how
do you know that he had sex on that
table
the toast
you can sing
you have to audition for the fellas you
were seeing titanium right
you know David Guetta have I been living
under a rock everyone knows that song
yeah
I'm leaving here until you sing so
this is problematic so weird cancel
Pitch Perfect so I'm tired
[Music]
and then they fall in love Yeah start
making out
that's why everyone loves this movie
[Music]
they're making strong eye contact no
they have really good chemistry yeah
lovely voice
thanks
see you at audition what
in bars of Kelly Clarkson Since You've
Been Gone if a group likes you
Christopher mint plazas in this WOW Nick
Lovin here's some things
[Music]
it was cool but it was all pretend and
yeah yeah
it's like theater kid 100 I'm sorry what
was that
fish
[Laughter]
say
[Music]
[Applause]
s
dude the editing in this is great yeah
it is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
he was the guy in that musical movie
that people didn't like
[Music]
but he also won like Tony's for that so
I'm aware he's got great like solo music
that I love I didn't know we had to
prepare that song oh that's okay sing
anything you want uh
man
oh yeah the cup thing what cup thing
have you seen this no but like it's a
trend
got my ticket for the long way round
ah that is cool when I'm gone
dude prettiest I was falling in love
with her I know you're gonna miss me
when I'm gone
damn that caught me nipple chill
[Music]
Colt that Amy Denise Ashley and Becca
wow it's like a cult that's what I just
said I don't listen to you
classic pun I know
[Music]
Benji he's with the Enemy
promise to never have sexual relations
with the Troublemaker or
[Music]
did I get you a drink sounds great I'm
gonna get you a drink go for it I think
you need to get on this level do you
want to have your vocal cords ripped out
by Wolves I think she does I mean she
was in Twilight so she's kind of
familiar with the Wolves so one of this
is probably a lesbian my money is on
Black Beauty so when I drink too much
tonight can I count on you to hold my
hair back if I puke
hahaha
[Laughter]
[Applause]
poor Ben I don't know his real name in
this movie he wasn't accepted
he's gotta probably some Asian he's
gonna be the villain watch he's gonna
like start his own or something the dark
side yes
this is his origin story and he likes
Star Wars so you know it's like the
parallels
Stacy The Trebles don't respect us and
if we let them penetrate us we are
giving them our power not a good enough
reason to use the word penetrate so
anything to confess
it was an accident I turn in your scarf
and go lady you vomited on stage you're
being way too harsh and it is my job to
make sure that my soldiers are prepped
at go time with three Kick-Ass songs and
there are only four months until
regionals so if you have a problem with
the way that I run the Bellas then you
should just
you know
this is a list of all of the songs that
we have ever performed we only do songs
made famous by women there's nothing
from the century on here because we
don't stray from tradition time to mix
it up if you want to win the competition
also wouldn't having sex with the other
team actually get in their heads and be
used as a weapon perhaps
ships
one
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we will work on that first thing
next time
she's so tight
for Jesse a musical boner I saw it at
Hood night it's distracting you're not
the blossoming you took an oath that
oath cost you two girls already today
I'm pretty sure you need me more than I
need you me to my boss well done
I think we're gonna be akka awesome
why do they look like flight attendants
I don't know
not paying for this let's go well I hope
you all remember the way you feel so you
will never gonna feel this way again God
your voice didn't sound aguilarian at
all I have nodes what oh my God
I just have to pull back Chloe this is
horrible well at least it's not herpes
or do you have that as well
[Laughter]
do you want me to get you lunch
probably lay off the burgers not gonna
be 22 forever you know
I think I'm good I love that guy's body
I want to be him I want to score movies
bring people to tears you know blow
their minds I feel like only music can
do that you must really sweep your
girlfriend off her feet oh I don't have
a girlfriend you have juice pouches and
Rocky
you just happen to guess the biggest
cinematic reveal in history Vader in
German means father his name is
literally Darth father oh what is that
real I didn't know that
are you guys getting ready for the Riff
Off what the hell is a riff-off exactly
what it sounds like this is West Side
Story
ladies of the 80s
[Applause]
this [__] is like so cool
especially like actually it was real
life this does not happen in college
if it did though college would have been
way cooler
um nice
[Music]
the negative side effects of medical
marijuana folks
wow I thought that was good
Sean's about sex all of them
Like a Virgin
[Music]
I've had goosebumps this whole time
I had to put the girl that got cut out
oh
[Music]
that brings out the man in me
nicely done
get in the ref off yeah
feels the very first time
oh [__] here we go
[Music]
now put it down never slow the original
rump shakers
what is she saying I don't know sorry
get down
lost strictly busy don't play around
much ground got game by the pounds what
is Spooby doing in my body
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at that what happens when you break
tradition I look how comfortable she is
they got the audience in with the
[Applause]
dude they're just jealous enjoy watching
us win the iccas on the TV on a regional
cable affiliate
I want to watch you watch the end of
this movie
such a good movie you've seen it right
it's a little overrated yes
princess and a criminal
does that answer your question
sincerely yours
a little lucky game yeah I thought he
was being watched
you're missing me sorry
oh
I knew it
oh yeah no one could predict it that is
that is so me though when I get too
nervous and I'm like I mean let's watch
another one
I think Becca should take my solo yeah
Becca would be excellent they might be
shy and not when I come forward and say
they wanted a solo
I would be happy to do it if I got to
pick a new song and do an arrangement
well that's not how we run things here
you can sing Turn the Beat Around and
that's the last I want to hear of this
you are so annoying that Amy
you'll solo
he was like weirdly okay with getting
insulted like that I would have been
like this you want to dress like a
flight attendant go for it that's what I
would have said she doesn't care enough
man maybe it's that she works too hard
so she gets jealous of her for not
working
or she's secretly a great singer and is
jealous
acapella is once again proven that it
doesn't get better for everyone After
High School
geez they're so mean oh my God the
Bellows are gonna have like a Mean Girls
moment that might provide some [__]
let's go
see the Bellas mixing it up it's a
refreshing yet displeasing to the eye
and Bella
is for saying song
and all eyes will be on senior Aubrey
Posen she could toss some cookies at any
moment
[Music]
throw up again
she makes it through folks no cookie
toss
for them I got like leg chills
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go
laughs
[Music]
awesome
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I love that
[Music]
now right around
God damn they're good
oh that's right John I'll have to excuse
me
jeez
e
[Music]
damn they're so good and then they
obviously won who else would win they're
way better
[Music]
the winner of tonight's Regional
competition defending
oh he's still a loyalist to them
yeah even after he was mistreated that
way I wonder what he's gonna do he's
gonna do something you know
they're all from a television show dude
really
I love him so much
she's looking excited
what have you done
it looked pretty serious that doesn't
mean you call my dad who else was I
going to call okay why are you yelling
at me I'm the only one here I didn't ask
you to be it's like a [__] tournament
if you think I'm paying for you to go to
La after a stunt like this I'm not get
in the car you're not even gonna hear
what I have to say about this No not
tonight just get in why don't you speak
up man literally there was like 50
people fighting there's so many people
getting it
she got friends
I want you to take the night shift play
your music the DJ at the garage does a
brilliant version of this but yours it's
better just gonna get pulled away from
the occupant no no
dick B2 bomb I have the semi-finals
tonight I did not have you pegged as an
acapella girl it's because you don't
know Becky like I do see you tonight I
don't think there's been enough screwing
time dedicated to this whole like
rivalry yeah maybe there were deleted
scenes or something
triangle
seems more just like a line it just
keeps like increasing every time we
check in and I'm like rarely here
Donald Slow Down slow down
[Music]
that is cruel that's so mean
I'm sitting up
[Laughter]
[Music]
laughs
we're all singing Greg I'm sorry yeah I
was more like why are my nipples so hard
just chills this whole every time they
break into a song I don't know why
we must love musicals Greg it can't be
you just feel the Phantom of the Opera's
next yeah I did yeah it's right right
Next Step because I got hit by flying
Mexican food oh she didn't put the gas
in the someone should have checked but
you guys are gonna get pitch slapped so
hard your man boobs are going to concave
[Music]
pretty good I set fires to feel Joy
oh
good times
[Music]
I wonder if these guys are like a real
acapella group I'm sure one of them is
[Applause]
I hate their outfits so much like please
change for at least one performance
[Music]
here we go again looks like they're
sticking with what they know God damn
it's so boring when you do this
[Music]
she can feel it
just break tradition
oh
oh she's getting a mischievous let's go
[Music]
she's gonna do remixes that everyone
yeah that like made me nervous though
steak can haunt you for the rest of your
life and affect your children facts
screw us up are you serious your grade a
pain in my ass and I know you're hooking
up with Jesse if this is what I get for
trying
[Music]
Bella that was so loud in my ear Craig
oh my God that's the benefit of now
being here instead of filming remotely
from New York
come on Ben Platt go after her and sing
a song
[Laughter]
okay High School
the Bellas do not advance and Senior
Aubrey Posen loses her chance to redeem
herself from last year's puke All Is
Lost
can't you walk slow
man she had it started off a loner and
started to gain friends but now she's
going backwards to being a loner yeah
relatable
oh my God she's finally getting what she
wanted but maybe is this what she really
wanted that's what she needs Greg I
don't I don't think so
character Arc
she's reminded me to reach out through
music oh yes that's true I didn't even
think that for some reason that but all
the obviousness
princess
does that answer your question
The Breakfast Club Fun Factory the whole
take they made her watch the entire
movie
just to really get in the camera yeah we
need a very realistic take yeah yeah we
are from the Collegiate acapella
Association it has come to our attention
that you are not in college
oh they'll get another chance now we're
breaking into act three people let's go
oh she looks good there holy [__] yes
thank you sir
why because she's winded Greg she was
yeah I prefer women exhausted
she was in True Blood season two I
remember her now
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love that bird
sorry
we will win without her you don't look
hot anymore
oh my god do you think there's gonna be
a woman in the room with him
gargled a little bit
because I probably couldn't do it again
oh he was watching a movie by himself so
now they can watch one together you push
away anyone who could possibly care
about you why is that
I don't know
he's like get therapy yeah
yeah Jesse Breaking Bad that's what it
is yeah I am the one who knocks
she said surgery [__] and Jessica and
Ashley it is like you haven't been here
all year long have we really we've
literally been here the whole time
[Laughter]
Chloe could you please get your head out
of your ass it's not a hat why don't
they just kick her out
dad
oh I like it
was listening uh this is about the
Bellas getting into the finals we
already know what are they watching
the weather all right
dust lamps I leave for Los Angeles in a
few hours so let's get going but bumper
what about the iccas there this weekend
I won that [__] like 100 times so I'm
out of here
he's leaving and then it's gonna be him
there's gonna be the leader I know
[Music]
you know he writes his own he knows
someone in a magical box if you
they will definitely not let you
just
come on I'm doing this group so I could
hang out with a bunch of really cool
chicks and also because I was really
sick of all my boyfriends and I need to
get away from that
I'm sure to listen to Becca oh so it's
my fault Aubry you're too controlling
and it's gonna ruin all of us this time
I'm not get down
[Music]
here
[Laughter]
it's like the Exorcist
oh my God
let it out
they're gonna slip in it and it's gonna
they're gonna like
oh do it
[Music]
I wanted to say that I'm sorry and I
definitely shouldn't have left
I let you guys down and I'm really sorry
[Music]
continuity issues I didn't see it when
she first stood up
[Music]
okay I know that I've been hard on you
but I am my father's daughter and he
always said if at first you don't
succeed pack your bags
[Music]
I guess we don't really know that much
about each other I have a lot of sex
yeah we nice I see only because I just
told you
for the last two years I've had a
serious
gambling problem one it started when I
broke up with my girlfriend well
hey my twin in the womb
[Laughter]
they gave her the best luck
[Music]
what do we do
it's so well done
oh her eyes her eyes make the stars look
like they're not shining her hair ah
this is so much better
um
[Music]
best move we've ever seen in a long time
this is cool they gotta have like a CD
huh oh yeah a CD guy still called him on
Spotify though yeah
one two
[Music]
what was that I don't know I've never
made that sound before is that you no it
was the movie I thought it was you no I
have something that can help us out
excuse me [__] you don't need to shout
she could sing baritone I swear to God I
thought that was you oh yeah
what the hell yeah
[Applause]
welcome to the finals of the 2000s here
we go here we go here we go
ready for it shut your eyes and get rid
of all the aqua Politics the Lincoln
Center here in the Big Apple and singing
on this storied stage is the dream of
every I hope those are all real acapella
groups they got to you know be in the
movie yeah I get a chance to shine
count down
[Music]
I bet Pentatonix was in this movie and
we just didn't even notice it yep
good luck
thanks you too
troublemakers have no idea what you're
going for but now they have been plot so
sometimes
[Music]
oh she loves him yeah
tonight
here we go here we go
I've got the magic in me
oh look at them respect
[Music]
oh I hope they win yeah
how about you with the eyes come on down
to the front and sit right here and
don't be shy so come on come on
God damn this is done so well
[Music]
[Applause]
I got the magic in me
I wonder if Ben Platt did more like
behind the scenes and stuff for this
movie
I don't know you know yeah okay let's
just smash this okay I don't know how
they're gonna beat it do you
how are they gonna beat that I don't
have a white board to lay it out for you
but Don are those Bella uniforms and
this is a whole new look for them and it
is hot hot junk these girls could turn
me
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh this is great
good
the hell are you doing in that audience
yes
let's go that's such a boss move
will you call my name oh this is
fantastic
[Music]
so they're gonna pierce my shirts
[Applause]
[Music]
see her hair wasn't down and the other
one and now it's down and then it's not
down they just accept it okay
[Music]
oh my God you ladies
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [__]
[Applause]
all right I see it yeah
[Music]
my eyes are watery yeah it's so awesome
you need tissues here I know I do this
is amazing
I don't even know why I'm so moved to
this whole movie are you oh my God
[Applause]
I love it Sally I love it
yeah that's what I'm talking about I
launched this year's auditions
email a recent icca National Champion
winners get to pick the audition song oh
hell yeah
[Music]
I know that was amazing you gotta come
back out here Sally I know it's just not
to say when we are zooming in together
[Music]
I think she directed the second one okay
I need to see that that was incredible
that was so good I figured literally it
was so like I'm just so happy yeah that
was amazing you should do a musical
series because I feel like it removed my
music you know what they had the man
that Kristoff packed some like music and
everything I watched these days
um the
I think the uh they had that line that
he was that what's the freaking guy's
name the love interest I don't know I
don't know I just can't I just I don't
remember his name
yeah it's called discount Dane Cook the
whole time
um
God he looks so familiar just making
sure there's no post credits and you
never know right yeah I wouldn't I would
know how that feels they had that
he was explaining that whole thing about
you know um you know music and
everything just booing your emotions and
moving you to tears and all that stuff
right and sure yeah I can experience
picking up his name so we can be proper
with this and not get turned out for
non-wing character names hold on but I
and I think this one
Chloe don't worry it's just God
punishing you because you're a ginger
[Laughter]
oh they did like little ad-libs
yeah the um the
I think yeah she is his name Jesse who's
the actor look him up we would have
waited I just went up here right there
which would have waited one second it
would have appeared
um Jesse Yeah I think the movie was just
so
because yeah like I mean sure it's
predictable and stuff and the movie's
telling you it was predictable like I
thought that was the whole point of that
scene when they when they have the DVDs
and she's saying how movie's going
you're like yeah you know it's
predictable so of course it's gonna
follow the structures and everything
it's gonna go the route you expect it to
go but they still made it unique in a
lot of the jokes that they
did it was way edgier than I expected
yeah
um what was the point of the DJ
now that now that we've seen the whole
thing I'm like he didn't come back at
the end there was nothing you remember
the whole like love triangle thing that
was like kind of weird like oh yeah well
I think that was just the path of I mean
I think for her character Becca it was
just showing how she would she thought
she wanted a specific path that this was
the real path that she a real calling no
no but I meant the character
specifically who cares he was hot and
had abs and was great I was I thought
that would come back at the end for
something so did I but it did not but
everything else came back at the end
like The Breakfast Club references that
was well done that was really well done
that was a great moment yeah it was and
and a great way for uh her to show how
much she's changed I don't know it's
just like sweet and cheesy this is the
kind of [__] that I'm out there crying
on camera because something is is just
so that's what usually makes me cry it's
like the heartbreaking uh like that's
not heartbreaking but just the real
touching stuff that people do you know
that's real touching that's some
touching ass [__] right there I love it
I love that movie
it was so fun you know this was one of
those movies that like everyone hyped up
so much because everyone loved this
movie that that's why I like put off
watching it does that ever happen to you
when it people like hype it up so much
that you like don't want to watch you
see the list of movies I have that I
gotta react to yeah
definitely lived up to it just because
of how different the dialogue was it was
fun to watch like there were moments
around like the puke moment where that
thing fell you know that you're just
like God that was hilarious you know
I I did not know it was an acapella
movie I I knew I knew it was something
to do with music because it's called
pitch perfect yeah and people have
always said like Anna Kendrick's a great
singer so I was like all right I'm
assuming that yeah there's some type of
musical I I thought they were I I had no
idea what it what it was about I had
never seen like a trailer or images or
something like that I saw a trailer for
Pitch Perfect three but I don't think
that communicated to me that they deal
with acapella so um and that was I saw
like one time years ago so yeah when
this movie started like oh [__] does it
knock up and I love acapella like who
doesn't love good good because if you
didn't what's your favorite acapella
song Greg uh I don't know any original
acapella no no I meant like what's your
favorite rendition of a song of an
object my God I have one you have a
specific one what Pentatonix did Kanye
West's coldest winter is it pronounced
Pentatonix yeah I'm
just no Pentatonix yes I don't know why
I enunciated just now pentatonic that's
how it's spelled Pentatonix but I just
say Pentatonix Pentatonix
is Pentatonix yes
I don't know why I just was like
Pentatonix yeah
you should listen to their uh Kanye West
uh version like yeah coldest winter on
their Christmas album I think it's gonna
promote Kanye West on this channel dope
he's the he's the personality I'm
striving to be
and I think it was interesting watching
this because I don't mind Rebel Wilson
um I've seen a bunch of Rebel Wilson
[__] after this movie which is the movie
that made her like really I know this is
the one that made her like really famous
and then I kind of started seeing Rebel
Wilson when she went through that phase
that everyone goes through where it's
like suddenly people really are annoyed
by Rebel Wilson all the time just
because she pops up and kind of does the
same kind of shtick all the time and
then people started going back to liking
her again yeah because she also like
came out about how she she was annoyed
herself that she kept getting like the
fat funny character roles you know yeah
she was like uh what is she British
Australian whatever foreign not American
version of Melissa McCarthy herself like
later was trying to like break out of
that type which Hollywood yeah kept
putting her in but she has a specific
kind of humor
um I could see why this movie made her
real like way more on the map like
because it's cool that she gets to not
only done atmosphere a comedy but also
demonstrate her like singing capability
she sold this show and a lot of
one-liners in this movie
and there were other characters like the
silent Asian girl that was like so funny
I just like what this movie was so much
funnier than I said yeah me too I
thought it would just be uh just a movie
proven for female audiences I really I
just also really like it because like
there's not many movies that there's all
girls that has this amount like this
great humor in it you know mean girls
that's why it's also cool that McLovin
was in this movie because like yeah it's
kind of like uh it's cool just to see an
all girls movie it's really funny
um like we got our super bad moment I
guess we did get our super bad moment
yeah it was it was funny and it was and
and the the directing and editing of the
musical numbers was so well done yeah it
was like watching a Pentatonix music
video besides but the way they would do
especially in the in the training
sequences and stuff like that that was
and I was just an admiration of knowing
like being aware of some of these people
who I only know as actors and not
musical performers and then seeing just
how much work they put into like I'm
watching this going I'm like it's a time
did it take to choreograph this
choreography all the sinking it's a lot
of lip syncing it's a lot of meshing of
different songs like remixes too and
then imagine too the legalities behind
that like having to get every song
cleared and like I wonder how much true
paid for all the copyright stuff that's
crazy well I wonder because it's a
universal movie so they probably own a
lot of it yeah they probably had a lot
of umg music which is the best company
on YouTube We love you umg they always
they're always like yeah the five two
seconds plays in a trailer you can keep
it they're never just we own your whole
video now even though you muted it yeah
they're great
um yeah I thought Anna Kendrick was
awesome too is this the movie that made
her like a lead performer yeah I'm
assuming yeah like a lead in general
she's I mean anytime she pops up in
anything it's weird she's in so much but
like as a celebrity she's not really
like there's she's so such an
unproblematic Queen you know just you
never really see her in the tabloids
oh and the reoccurring motif of the uh
the the the commentators was his name
John something oh man look his name I
want to make sure I'm getting this [__]
right attempt to Anna Kendrick and not
they Pitch Perfect
um Elizabeth Banks and uh what is what
is John Michael John what is his [__]
name
what is it do you know it
I know who you're talking about but he's
John Michael Higgins that's his name
yeah John Michael Higgins and Elizabeth
Banks they're great oh my God they were
hysterical I think Elizabeth Banks is
such a still to this day I mean she's
been becoming more of a director uh and
she still does stuff in front of the
camera but I think she's like an
underrated comedic Talent uh and then
this this movie just shows that off so
much okay we gotta look up where it is
Skyler Aston guys from
because damn
I just kept looking at his face going
I've seen this dude in something else oh
it's facial hair maybe we would know
because I just saw a picture of him a
facial hair and he looks
let's see
oh crazy ex-girlfriend God damn it he
was the he was Greg and crazy Have You
Seen Crazy Ex-Girlfriend
you guys have not seen crazy X you oh my
God it's brilliant
have you seen any of it
I know what it is you haven't even seen
him like one Emmys right you haven't
even seen like the musical numbers I've
seen a few
um I have seen a few uh because I I had
an ex that watched it
crazy ex-boyfriend actually hey it's
just a movie I mean a show so you would
love that show I know it is so inventive
and and I was hoping the first and it's
like deep too but hilarious how many
seasons there's only three but every
every episode there's not a lot of
episodes there's like a difference kind
of music
for every episode like yeah yeah they're
very creative and they mix up the genres
um and yeah I've heard it's incredible I
definitely need to watch it because I
love anything with music and he plays a
character uh in one of the later Seasons
like he replaces a character
um character yeah he's a character
character and that was that's where I've
seen him from that's right that makes
sense because he sings and [__] in there
yeah it looks like he's doing all he
does trolls as well
he's also in trolls yes the new one or
tro the show and then
uh yeah he was good he was really nice
he was really nice yeah in that show he
plays like nice likable guy yeah yeah
he's good at that he's good at playing
Knights like a boca Adam DeVine have you
seen that movie where like he tries to
get with this the girl like he goes back
in time to constantly try to get with
his friend no he's in that movie he's a
lead in it he's really good the
butterfly Factor no that movie is so fun
but yeah guys this was a great great
cast of characters yes some of some of
the the only bit that I thought was
weird was the thing with the room shower
the shower
I thought that I didn't quite understand
the choices for that bit I thought that
like she was gonna be a singer and then
like join them or something like she was
like jealous of her or something like
you're that never came back at the end
either like it was the point of that I
didn't understand a lot of the the I
didn't quite find Detroit it's not I
didn't understand it was like there must
have been so many deleted scenes the
choice for it didn't feel strong to me
and it it just rang as a little weird
and then it didn't uh and it just says
have a good spring break I'm like I
guess they get along now or something I
kind of shipped Anna Kendrick and
Brittany Snow together you know I
thought they were yeah I thought they
would have been excellent but yeah all
the other everyone in the in the team of
the Bellows were so were wonderful they
were all they did a perfect podcasting
yeah yes this was diverse and a lot of
ways
um yeah musical numbers are amazing
everything about this movie I thought
was great yeah I I really enjoyed this
movie a lot I had so much fun it was
like a surprisingly fun yeah it was a
fun movie to watch yeah
because sometimes when we when I when we
film here especially when I got people
who are filming like a Sally knows the
situation today I was like yeah just
come over uh and then we'll let's just
look what do I got so and then yeah I
like to make it a little spontaneous
sometime and to find the spontaneous
decision that was about embracing
spontaneity
this was the perfect choice Perfect
Choice pitch perfect perfect choice not
a perfect movie but um but for what it
sets out to do it's like near perfect
the pitch was perfect ah
well done yeah well done and everyone on
Rotten Tomatoes likes it too except one
person who probably hates music and
hates themselves and you know and what's
refreshing about watching this movie to
me as well
see why they got her for trolls too
because for sure because they kind of do
like a similar thing with their songs
and [__]
um
that's a great trip I didn't expect to
love that either and I was like this is
a really fun movie
um the the a lot of times like people
might complain about the use of familiar
songs and [__] that plays on Nostalgia
and this movie manages of course to hit
that note
however Beyond just hitting a familiar
note they've they find ways of making of
like Reinventing and making it really
creative and super engaging well they
added in a lot of this the popular songs
when this movie came out at the time and
mixing that with the nostalgic 80s deal
like there were a lot of 80s songs in
this movie God this movie's 11 years old
I love 80s music I feel like this movie
just came out like a couple years 11
years old I'm old you are old and you're
a woman so I'm kind of times up by two
I started out you put our lighting Greg
you can see my wrinkles
you look great Sally people are gonna
love the way you look
right okay yes comment about Sally's
looks in this video and not about her
personality yeah guys okay someone needs
to comment and it needs to get a lot of
likes and I need Greg to do The Cup Song
from this movie like we should do the
cup song challenge it's like a challenge
that was like a popular thing yes it
still is like people still do it yeah
I've never seen it yeah really well
they're banning tick tock
the government good thing we have
YouTube yeah I'll do the cup thing here
do the cup challenge whatever the cup
challenge this thing we should both do
it and see who does it perfectly pitch
perfectly
oh I can't wait to watch the second one
yeah you gotta come back out here you
gotta pay money fly out here literally
my mom I like FaceTime her today she's
like you can just fly out there whenever
you know like you just go to LAX
[Laughter]
and uh and I won't pay you anything
that's fine that was amazing I was so
surprised Sally I'm glad we chose this
one me too this is probably it's
probably out of all the ones we've
covered of the movies we've covered
together this is probably the most the
most fun one
I would say I would say we've had odd
choices we've had really weird ones that
are like this is fun but it kind of tips
some of them dip in and out yeah
Spaceballs was hard for us
grown-ups like we did grown as time like
we were fun but this was like oh man I
love this is the first one by surprise
many times and I don't think we had seen
a movie yet that had done that for us I
also cried so or I laughed so hard I
cried in the beginning and that was
awful because I just did my makeup and I
was like I can't there's no tissues that
that was a great spontaneous moment uh
I think this is the first time we
watched together but we loved it yeah
yeah like genuinely loved it yeah oh
what a blast what a blasting blast of a
situation well thanks for watching guys
thanks for being here follow Sally she's
a gem
Cherry Bomb I know Cherry Bomb
you get do you get Ever ashy knees no I
get ashy knees it's no problem I
actually have a scar there and I keep
forgetting like I can see it on camera
but I don't know if it actually
I ate [__] as a kid off a bike
like you ate bad food while on a bike no
I like had a bike accident and like a
third person oh like second grade uh it
was pretty gnarly
um
yeah so that's from that
it was like it was like all this and
then all I literally see nothing really
this right here it was like a big chunk
just taken out of my skin so you can see
like a circle there that's white that is
so not noticeable yeah I mean it's
obviously like gone down over the years
they're there I'm right here and I can
tell you there's like nothing there it's
a contrast on your TV it's like you can
like see it right there it'll be clearer
on the camera
camera yeah the camera that shoots us
yeah the shooting of the camera
[Music]
poison specifically designed to kill
Cusco
oh I missed you Craig I miss you too
Sally anyway guys follow Sally keep a
lookout for a Spider-Man short film
she's gonna also try to like show
me that would look so good she's gonna
drop all her Marvel movie reactions at
once
you know what we should do we should we
should have you film all hours just
hours I'm so down and then I'll tell my
boss that my flight's canceled and I'll
just do all the movies here I'll only
show your reactions to the like the last
five minutes of each one of them yeah
Sally choice
I'm mine blamer all right guys thank you
for being here you check us on patreon
leave a like
[Music]